good evening and welcome to all of you
I'm Jim Plummer the Dean of the
engineering school and we're delighted
to have all of you here tonight we have
a large crowd I think almost every seats
taken in the auditorium here and
hundreds more who are actually watching
because this event is being webcast this
evening as well so as you all know we're
here tonight to celebrate and to honor
professor emeritus Marty Hellman for his
induction as a Stanford engineering hero
we're also delighted to have Marty's
wife Dorothy with us tonight and his
daughter and granddaughter as well so
welcome to all of you the Stanford
engineering heroes program was started
about three years ago and it recognizes
the achievements of Stanford engineers
who have profoundly changed or advanced
the course of human social and economic
progress through engineering so far
there are 23 heroes that we've named to
this point and typically each year there
are half a dozen or so that we named
newly each year and they're named
because of their contributions to
innovation to entrepreneurship to
leadership and to world-class teaching
and research along with Marty this
year's inductees include yahoo founders
Jerry Yang and David Philo earthquake
engineering pioneer John Blum and bill
Perry who is a former as you all know
former Secretary of Defense and will
hopefully be hearing from many of them
in the weeks and months to come at
events like this prior engineering
heroes include people like Fred Terman
Bill Hewlett Dave Packard and Vint Cerf
so it's a very illustrious group of
people we're just proud to have people
like this associated with the
engineering school and to honor the
contributions that they've made to not
just the engineering school here but to
the world more broadly
unlike many award ceremonies and so on
the only thing we ask of people who were
honoring is how they would like to spend
some time at Stanford and Marty like
many of the previous recipients
suggested that we basically set up some
time for him to spend time with Stanford
students and so he I think last week
spent some time with some undergraduates
in the stand
for science technology and society
program and then this afternoon and
evening he spent some time with some
mostly graduate students but also I
think one or two undergrads in the
computer science department who work in
the cryptography field primarily marty
also suggested the topic of his talk for
this evening which interestingly as you
all know is called the wisdom of
foolishness and so this is something I'm
very much looking forward to as I'm sure
he will tell you and I won't try and
give his talk for him he's going to talk
about the fact that major
accomplishments often require a certain
amount of foolishness and there probably
are other terms you could use not being
afraid to take risks not being afraid of
failure and so on but he'll here you
will I think tell us by way of example
and some things that he's done in his
career about the importance of being
bold in the projects and problems that
you take on so as all of you know marty
is best known as the inventor along with
Whitfield Diffie and Ralph Merkle of
public key cryptography in 1976 and this
this is actually a great example of the
wisdom of foolishness because as I'm
sure Marty will tell you he was I'm sure
given plenty of advice when he decided
to work in this area that he was foolish
to toil in an area that was dominated by
the US National Security Agency and its
enormous budget however today as all of
you know public key cryptography secures
trillions of dollars of financial
transactions that all of us make use of
every day when we use the internet for
banking and shopping and so on well
Marty also has a very deep and abiding
interest in the ethics of technological
development he's a longtime activist in
the computer privacy debate and for the
past several years he's campaigned to
raise awareness of the urgent need to
defuse the threat of nuclear nuclear
weapons and he does this by thinking
about the problems using engineering
principles principles like risk analysis
and thinks through problems that and
that engineering allows him to think
about clearly and hopefully to have good
solutions to so this approach to
worrying about nuclear or thinking about
nuclear weapons
has really one tremendous support for
his work from Nobel laureates military
leaders academics and and government
leaders who've seen tremendous value and
how he's thought through many of these
issues so in this work and in other work
such as his connections with the
international beyond war foundation in
our view Marty truly embodies what we
mean by an engineering hero he's shown
how engineering problem solving methods
can allow you to take on problems which
are well beyond traditional engineering
disciplines so Marty earned his graduate
degrees here at Stanford and went off to
a small place on the East Coast to teach
it's the Massachusetts something or
other before he saw the wisdom of living
in the Burien came back to Stanford as a
faculty member in 1971 and his work as
all of you know in the cryptography
field has been recognized by numerous
awards I Triple E Hamming medal the
national computer system security award
he's a Marconi international fellow
National Academy of Engineering member
and International Association for
archaeological research member in a
night in 2011 Marty and his colleagues
were inducted into the National
Inventors Hall of Fame recognizing the
work that they did in this field so
tonight we celebrate Marty as the the
latest of our engineering heroes and
those of you who came in obviously came
in through the back door but the wall
down to the right has a has pictures of
all of the engineering heroes and
there's a plaque like this for each of
them there which you can go and look at
afterwards and Marty we have a replica
of this plaque to give to you tonight
which you're welcome to take home and
put on your desk or wherever else you'd
like to put it but please join me in
welcoming our latest engineering hero
Marty Hellman
well thank you Jim I couldn't have done
what I've done in this career without
the staff without Stanford University's
School of Engineering it as we discussed
over dinner it's provided the
environment that made this possible I
also want to thank the school for this
award it means a lot to me both because
it's coming from my colleagues and
because of a conversation you and I had
a few months ago when you told me that
I'd been selected for this August group
and why me was my reaction but I'm
really glad and I assumed that it was
for my work in cryptography as most of
my awards are and Jim said no this is
for your body of work including my work
with minority students in the 80s and
90s including my work on reducing the
threat posed by nuclear weapons and that
makes it doubly meaningful to me so
thank you I'd like to thank you all for
coming out tonight and I need to thank
my partners in foolishness and I'm used
that in the best sense of the word in
cryptography of course with Diffie and
ralph merkle the co-inventors of public
key cryptography and when I worked on
diffusing ethnic tension on campus I
need to really thank the students they
particular minority students who shared
with me at a very deep level crossing
over boundaries that normally were not
crossed over so I could really
understand what was going on and in
terms of reducing the threat posed by
nuclear weapons the first person I've
got to thank is my wife because when
people ask me how I moved from
cryptography to this issue the short
answer is Dorothy
she got me interested and also I've
learned so much from her about how
interpersonal relations are seemingly
insoluble problems can be solved that
it's given me the optimism needed to
think that the same could happen at the
international level and it's very much
the same kind of problem as I see it I
also want to thank the thousands of
people who have taken that issue to
heart and especially those my colleagues
from beyond war in the 80s some of
who were here tonight the goal of the
talk is to look at the wisdom of
foolishness and really to encourage more
people to take on what might seem like a
fool's errand and to see how doing that
can sometimes be very wise and can even
make major advances in society and so
it's kind of ironic that the last thing
most people want to appear especially at
a place like Stanford and especially in
engineering is foolish because the
reason I'm here tonight giving this talk
is because I did a lot of foolish things
and I'll go through some of them tonight
when I first using cryptography as an
example when I first started working it
in the late 60s and early 70s I was told
by almost all maybe that all my
colleagues that I was crazy to do this
because NSA they had two typical reasons
NSA had this humongous budget we didn't
know how big but it may well be bigger
than the CIA's budget NSA stands for
never say anything or no such agency and
also they had decades Head Start how
could I hope to discover something they
didn't already know
now both those arguments were very valid
both those arguments came to haunt me
but in hindsight it was very wise to do
something so foolish and let me just
treat the second argument if you do
something good they'll classify it
July 1977 so the the key result was
actually in the spring of 76 working in
my study we were discussing this about
1:00 in the morning I put some things
together and it came out but so we
published that paper already and we were
starting to publish good things in
cryptography and it was getting NSA
concerned and so I get a letter from the
I Triple E in July 77 that's the primary
electrical engineering professional
Society and they sent it to me because I
was publishing my papers there and an
IEEE triple-a member living in Maryland
had written from his home address
pointing out that the I Triple E was
breaking the law and he'd never said
exactly by publishing my papers he said
publishing papers in cryptography and he
cited several journal issues where I had
papers and so the I Triple E wrote back
to him and they sent a copy to me saying
yeah we're well aware of that law but
it's always been our position at the I
Triple E that we can't make sure we
can't decide whether papers break it or
not it's up to the authors and their
institutions it's their responsibility
and so I took this letter to Stanford
general counsel who at the time was John
Schwarz and for two reasons one the
university was potentially liable and
secondly if I was prosecuted I wanted to
make sure I had the university's
financial backing behind me because you
can't go bankrupt yourself you can't
mount a good defense and so I'll never
forget the second meeting I had with
John cuz the first one I present the
material to him he goes and studies it
and I come back and he says okay I've
studied it it's my legal opinion that if
this law is construed broadly enough to
cover your work then it's
unconstitutional freedom of speech
freedom of press but then and this is
the key part he warns me says but I
gotta warn you if you're prosecuted we
will defend you if you're convicted will
appeal but if all appeals are exhausted
we can't go to jail for you
oh and the guy who wrote from his home
address in Maryland work trying to say
we found out later he never told us that
but we were able to determine that and
so we weren't sure but this looked like
it might be NSA base telling us and
there was a lot of unhappiness in the
agency because we were publishing papers
that they would have classified above
top secret there were reasons for it to
protect your medical records to protect
we could see the computer revolution
computer communications revolution
coming and so John said one other thing
so I felt comfortable because I I was
this was post Watergate and so you know
we can't tell you why but for reasons of
national security please be quiet didn't
hold much water in 1977 but John said
one other thing I had two papers with
students Route one with Ralph Merkle and
the other was with Steve poling at a
conference coming up in October 77 three
months later at Cornell University and
normally the students I would have the
students give the papers they give them
the spotlight and John said I strongly
recommend that you give the papers
rather than the students because there
was a question as to whether the
university could expend funds defending
a student versus an agent of the
university who's bringing contract funds
in me but he said even more important
way from a practical point of view you
have tenure your career can withstand a
multi-year court case which this was
likely to be if it went to court a newly
minted PhD not so good so I went to
Ralph and I went to Steve and explained
what John had told me and I said you
know with the university's financial
backing I'm not afraid to go forward
with this I'm confident we will prevail
and I said whatever you want to do is
fine with me
and they both initially said no we'll
give the papers about a week later they
come back to me
their parents have been beating on him
and so to please their parents I gave
the papers but at the conference I
wanted them to get the credit they
deserved and so and when it was time I
brought
and with both of us went up to the
podium and I said normally Steve or
Ralph would be giving the paper but on
advice of Stanford general counsel and
everyone knew what that meant
I'll be giving the paper but I want him
to get the credit he deserves so even
though he's standing mute beside me
please consider the words coming from my
mouth as if they're coming from him and
he got they got more attention that way
than they ever would have by giving the
papers now for several you we were not
arrested at the conference there was
some concern we might be and for several
years later after that there was concern
that and there were repeated attempts by
the government to pass legislation that
made it crystal clear that publishing
papers in cryptography and some other
areas that they added on were borne
classified that is even though we'd had
never had any access to classified
information in the area it would be
against the law to publish these papers
but fortunately they moved to a
voluntary system and I have to credit
Admiral Bobby Inman who was director of
NSA at the time for this
he thought outside the box and he still
does he's an amazing man and while
initially I kind of saw him as Darth
Vader because it felt to me and maybe
even he was trying to throw me in jail
against the advice he told me later of
all the senior people at NSA because
that the directorship is a rotating
position you come in for a few years and
you leave
he had a call placed to me and had a
meeting set up with me when he was out
in California we met in my office and
Duran 135 where it was in those days and
his first words were it's nice to see
you don't have horns which is what he
was hearing at NSA and I looked at him
and I said yeah it is nice and well
initially it was cautious we eventually
started working together and today we
regard each other as friends he's one of
the signers of my statement saying that
we should apply a quantitative risk
analysis then today public key
cryptography protects literally
trillions of dollars every day in
actions by the way I only found that out
the summer someone used that number to
sit come on you mean trillions of
dollars a year but it turns out it's
trillions of dollars a day in financial
transactions foreign exchange
transactions alone constitute four
trillion dollars a day and almost all of
those if not all of them are protected
using public key cryptography at a more
personal level when you buy something on
the internet we all know the Internet is
insecure was designed that way so how
does your credit card number flowing
over the Internet
how is it protected well with public key
cryptography now what is so it was very
wise even though the naysayers were
right that it was foolish to do this
thing it turned out to be very wise what
is public key cryptography and how does
it work I'll just give a kind of a
surface level explanation a full
mathematical explanation would take a
couple of hours and is beyond the
mathematical level of this talk imagine
I have a note I write out here and I
want to pass it John over there my
Brenden middle of the room I want to
pass it to him and I don't want any of
you to know what it's saying and we've
made no prearrangement have we John okay
not only so I write it out and I put it
in a strongbox and I walk it with a
combination lock then he doesn't know
the combination to it because there's no
prearrangement
he can't open it but neither can Farouk
neither can you or you or you and it
gets to John he can't open it either but
it's been secure getting to him now this
box has been designed in a special way
to locks can fit on it
he puts his lock on it everybody's got a
walk and everybody knows the combination
to his or her own lock and now I was
dumped it's doubly locked he passes it
forward again Ferb can you open it
because it has two walks that you don't
know how to open I can take off my rock
but I can't take off his but now I pass
the box back you can't open it because
it's got John's walk on it when John
gets it he can open it cuz it has his
lock and a mat if you can mathematize it
that's roughly what public key
cryptography does I'd like to give you
some examples of but this isn't unique
to me over dinner we were talking and
Jim agreed and Dan Bona agreed professor
in computer science that some of the
best work they do appeared foolish a
priori before they had the good result
and in preparation for this talk I
contacted for friends and colleagues who
I knew had had a similar experience and
I'm sure there are many and actually I
know many more but I'm sure there are
more I don't know about Vince surf
School of Engineering here I'll former
professor of computer science internet
pioneer one of the true fathers of the
Internet
he wrote to me packet switching was
regarded as crazy even after the great
example of the ARPANET most conventional
communications engineers thought it
would not handle speech let alone video
how many of you watched Netflix or
Amazon streaming video of course he then
writes it got better and better over
time the naysayers believed that store
and Ford would have too high a latency
to be useful they were wrong John Chafee
my colleague in electrical engineering
father of DSL the technology that brings
broadband communications to 70% of the
world he wrote back in 1979 as a young
kid fresh out of Stanford with his PhD I
got laughed out of the room in my first
DSL meeting at Bell Labs when I pushed
for more speed than 160 kilobits per
second then coming into discussion I
said 1 and 1/2 megabits per second
should be possible on the existing
twisted pairs
end quote today dsl speeds are more than
100 times greater than John's prediction
and it provides 70% of the worldwide
broadband connection we have cable
option very often in this country and on
campus I have Google Fiber now but most
people cable TV is not present in most
parts of the world so it's the phone
company in DSL that provides most
people's high speed connection
Federico for Jeanne the designer of the
first microprocessor and Ted Hoff it's
architect had the same thing happened to
them and I wrote to Federico and here's
what he wrote back in 1970 when I was
designing the world's first
microprocessor the CEO of American
Microsystems
and the largest producer of random logic
custom integrated circuits now that's a
technology which lost a lot of market
share to microprocessors that CEO was
quoted in electronics news as saying
something like and this is a quote
whoever thinks that a CPU he couldn't
call it a microprocessor because that
word had not been coined yet whoever
thinks that a CPU will replace random
logic is out of his mind coming back to
federico now talking again in his email
to me i remember cutting out that
article and posting it in my office as
an added incentive to prove such myopic
observation raw Brad Parkinson and his
hero lecture Oh event is a school of
engineering hero as is Brad Parkinson
grad emeritus in Aero and Astro and he
was the chief architect and I think the
chief salesman for GPS when everybody
thought it was crazy here's what he
wrote the air for the air force thought
GPS was foolish they saw no value in
precision weapons delivery and certainly
did not identify with the civilian
applications which I that is Brad told
Congress was part of the system from the
very beginning they also thought that
the user equipment would be prohibitive
and in fact it was at first but we could
foresee the digital revolution underway
Brad continues the first GPS units
weighed about 150 pounds used about two
kilowatts of electricity and cost about
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
each today a GPS receiver fits on a chip
weighing a fraction of an ounce uses
milliwatts of power and costs about $2
now you pay a lot more than that for a
GPS device because there's more than GPS
receiver in it plus profit margins Brad
goes on to write men are so blind as
they who refused to see the airforce
generally persisted in their view until
the first Gulf War showed what the
system could do ok there are many more
examples but with those four I hope you
see that many maybe even most great
advances appear foolish when they're
first being worked on before they've
paid off so
don't be afraid to do that when the
first time I gave a talk like this
students came up to me afterward and
said I'm gonna go back and look at some
research problems that I've put aside I
was telling Jim I wish I'd gotten their
email addresses and could find out how
many paid off now returning to my own
personal experiences with the wisdom of
foolishness I have another example which
I really like because it didn't take any
advanced degrees it didn't take advanced
mathematics all it took was curiosity a
power meter which cost about $30 so
anybody can buy one of those and
critical being foolish enough to think
the government might actually be
interested in improving its regulations
so here's what happened I bought a new
TV late in 2008 major premium brand of
TV so not bottom-of-the-line
and it was going in a place where we
rarely watched it it was just occasional
use and so I wanted to make sure that
its power consumption when it was off
was really low because most electronics
devices today only go into standby mode
they still draw power this one was
advertised as drawing less than 1/10 of
a watt really small but I did what I do
with all new appliances when I got it I
plugged it into my power meter let it
sit for a few days in what should be
standby mode and found the damn thing
was drawing 15 watts average a hundred
and fifty times the specification the
manufacturers have almost no use in
helping me figure it out but some
detective work I figured out what was
going on I thought that the TV was
either on or in standby mode when it was
plugged in but there's a third mode that
had just come into into use called
download acquisition mode there's that's
the free electronic program guide that
you can give us like a TV Guide and it's
downloaded over when you're sets off
it's being in download acquisition mode
it's being downloaded it was drawing 20
watts in download acquisition mode 75%
of the time which averages out to 15
watts the other at the time it was
drawing almost nothing so I called the
EPA and I was really fortunate Kathryn
Kaplan wasn't
charge of writing the EPA TV Energy Star
guidelines and when I told her what I
found she was living she said download
acquisition mode was a new thing when we
when we wrote the current version that
your TV was manufactured under and but
we never expected it would draw that
kind of power and so she agreed that
they would write some limits on download
acquisition mode into the djinn to the
standard she was just working on at that
time which is fortunate because they
don't this only happens about every two
years and so I got in at just the right
time I participated in a couple of
teleconference calls with the
manufacturers and they were all saying
they can't do it they were really happy
they'd gotten it down to 20 watts they
it had been 80 Watts before now I'm not
a hardware type but I was a ham radio
operator knew something about TVs and
receivers I said it seems to act they
should be able to do it with it five
watts should be generous and even one
watt looked possible I later found out
from the chief scientist at atheros
which who did know this stuff that five
watts was very possible one watt was not
at the current point in time in
2008-2009 but it would be probably in a
few years and so over the objections of
the industry the standard that's been in
place for several years now limits
download acquisition mode and so what's
been saved I estimate at least 10
billion kilowatt hours of electricity
were saved by the stant by this change
and possibly a hundred billion kilowatt
hours or more okay what's that in
dollars and cents that's at least a
billion dollars of electricity the
consumers have saved and possibly ten
billion probably several billion and
maybe ten billion now I could be wrong I
mean me is there a number of factors to
go in there but it's it's a lot of
electricity a lot of carbon dioxide no a
lot of money a full home run that only
took curiosity a $30 power meter might
actually cost 150 it's a little better
than the cheapest
and the foolishness to actually call via
EPA because but you know 90% of 99% of
the time when I do things like that it
does not pay off I'd like to turn to
another fools fool fool's errand that
became a fool's home run and this was
the work and beyond war in the 80s
Ronald Reagan came into office in
January 1981 and he brought the nuclear
threat into sharp focus now the nuclear
war fighting plans the war fighting
points in general were not that
different from what they were under
Jimmy Carter who won a Nobel Peace Prize
some years later but Reagan was more
honest about it and he talked in the
first few years he changed in his second
administration he talked about
eliminating these weapons but in the
first three or four years all the talk
was about fighting and winning a nuclear
war and that got a lot of us really
concerned and it focused our attention
and out of that came this group called
beyond war which I worked in along with
my wife and some of the other people in
the audience today it was foolish for
all of us to think that we could change
society's thinking about war even if
human survival demanded that in the
nuclear age but we were foolish enough
to do it my wife left her career as the
CPA at two Shroff's headed for a
partnership I took a year and a half
we've from the University without pay to
work on this issue and the number of the
people in the audience did similar
things or pulled out as much time as
they can I hope our children will
forgive us for all the time we didn't
spend with them as part of that process
we invited people into our living rooms
and would talk about the issue try to
get more people involved because it was
going to take a societal change and one
of the objections that came up
repeatedly was we can meet this way and
try to change our government's policies
but what's the use the Russians can't do
that well we had two answers to that
first of all we're in a coupled system
here if the United States were to start
to base its national security on
rational thinking instead of mythology
which is what's involved in
my opinion and my conviction I should
say we're nuclear policies concerned
mutually assured destruction is that a
policy or wishful thinking if we change
it's a couple system they have to change
and in fact what happens is they change
before we did and we changed somewhat in
response not enough in my opinion but we
felt it would be really helpful if we
could have some kind of meaningful
dialogue with some entity in the Soviet
Union now we knew that was impossible
because there was censorship there
Dorothy and I had been fortunate enough
to have Soviet information theorists
into our home both in Cambridge when I
was teaching at that little junior
college and and in Cambridge and out
here at Stanford and in some cases we
had very honest political discussions
with some of these information theories
never won there were other Russians
around because they could get in trouble
for that and never when I was in the
Soviet Union in a hotel room because was
probably bugged so we knew we couldn't
have that kind of dialogue openly but we
had other reasons why it still made
sense to go although it was a fool's
errand so September 1984 Dorothy and I
pack off leaving you in charge of and
Kelly and we went to Moscow and met with
some of the top scientists in the Soviet
Union working on arms control and
related policies and we sensed something
was really different when we met with
the peace committee which I called the
war committee or the Friendship Society
the Soviet Friendship Society that was
the Soviet hate Society because if you
disagree as long as you went along with
the US was bad that's it they were happy
to talk to you as soon as you pointed
out anything the Soviet Union was doing
wrong they were you know they were all
over you but these scientists were
different they asked us questions
because what we were saying conflicted
with the party line over there in
particular wars of national liberation
were too dangerous in the nuclear age we
argued and that's what they all asked us
they said what about Wars of national
liberation what about the blacks in
South Africa what are we supposed to
tell them and our answer was if you
could come to see that continuing to
support violent Wars of national
liberation
meant the inevitable destruction of the
Soviet Union in a nuclear war do you
think you could find another way to free
the blacks in South Africa which by the
way happened I mean we didn't know it
then now the interesting thing that did
happen was they didn't argue with us if
it had been the friendship society or
the peace committee they would have
argued with us but these guys didn't
agree with us they couldn't do that that
would get them in trouble but they
didn't argue with us we could tell they
were thinking about it we didn't know it
at the time but we were meeting with men
who were in the forefront of what became
Gorbachev's reform movement he didn't
come out of nowhere and these were the
people that were creating that fertile
environment and six months later
Gorbachev did come to power in March of
85 about a year later actually a year
and a half later late in 86 he had
enough consolidated enough power he was
able to lift censorship and suddenly the
project that we had longed to do became
possible and in very quick time by late
87 with a lot of help from the thousands
of people working in beyond war and help
from the Soviet Academy of Sciences a
very unusual hookup you can imagine we
had a book called breakthrough emerging
new thinking which was a breakthrough in
many ways it was the first place I
believe where Soviet authors questioned
their involvement in Afghanistan
certainly the first time for a Western
audience and it came out in Russian over
there and in English here simultaneously
we got an endorsement from Gorbachev and
I can't be sure but I believe that the
conversations we had the ideas that we
were putting into that system had some
impact some of the things we brought up
with the scientists I would see
Gorbachev talking about later
now other groups were meeting with these
people to not just us but I think it had
some impact so a full homerun who but a
fool would go to the Soviet Union in
1984 trying to start this and by the way
I can't take credit for the timing it's
really good we started in 84 because it
took two years to build the trust to
build the understanding so that when it
became possible to do the project we
could get it out like that if we waited
until it made sense it never would have
happened things would have changed too
fast
and so I sometimes say that God rewards
fools he smiles on you now I've given
examples of fool homeruns but of course
there are a lot of fool foul balls and
in fact there are too many for me to
enumerate I can't remember all of them
but as we were discussing over dinner to
have one research idea or one idea of
any kind really pay off that's a full
homerun you've got to probably try at
least twenty ideas and so I described
these two swinging wild pitches so the
picture comes in it's really wild that I
swing in it
okay that's idea number one it fails I
miss idea number two comes in but I'm
not worried I get excited by this idea I
swing in it strike out again this
happens 19 times in a row who but a fool
would be excited by idea number 20 which
a priority looks no different from the
first 19 ideas which really were foolish
but if you're not excited by idea number
20 the one that's going to pay off you
have no hope of succeeding because
you've got to believe it's going to pay
off another example of foolishness
paying off now there's another side to
it there is an example of seemingly wise
that is prudent behavior ending up being
foolish and dance that I can tell this
story Dan Boehner Google as you know
came out of the research of two graduate
students here in CS and so people in EE
and CS were the first ones to be using
this great new search engine John Gill
in fact told me about it and so dan and
I are talking one day and was saying
it's a great search engine but how are
they going to make money out of this how
can you make money from free search well
a very seemingly prudent feet on the
ground approach and we lost out on
making millions of dollars we should
have asked the question as a question
instead of make using the question as a
statement how the hell are they going to
make money from free search we should
have said how could they make money from
free search
my I'd like to turn in the last part of
the talk to my current fools earned
which is a continuation of the work from
beyond war and breakthrough which is
reducing the risk posed by nuclear
weapons and I should say the reason we
called it beyond war is we realized
early on in the researching this and we
had a number of engineers involved in
this
we recognized you had to take a system
view you can't just deal with the
nuclear threat and isolation that it was
totally coupled to the threat of
conventional war
like why does Iran want nuclear weapons
today part of it has to do with the
iran-iraq war of the 1980s when they had
to have gas masks in their closets and
nobody in the world made any objection
to Saddam Hussein using chemical weapons
against them no UN resolutions against
the aggressor Saddam Hussein instead we
kept selling them components and so
beyond war recognized that we had to
take a systems view of the problem and
really solve the the problem in total
instead of trying to just tweak this
little part over here oh I should point
out that I found it very impressive that
two out of the seven school of
engineering heroes inducted this year
have made reducing the threat posed by
nuclear weapons to be their life's work
from now on myself and Bill Perry oh and
I do have at the end of the talk some
DVDs that bill along with George Shultz
Ronald Reagan's Secretary of State Henry
Kissinger you know who he is and Sam
Nunn another person US statesman they
have a project called the nuclear
security project and they have a video
called the nuclear tipping point and I
have about a hundred of the DVDs here
which if we run out you can get them
online oh and I forgot to mention I've
written up some notes for this talk I
mean not the whole talk but it's got
some links to things including where you
can get that free DVD and if you google
stick Martin Hellman Stanford University
you'll get to my home page or if you go
to the hero page they're gonna put a
link but if you go to my home Stanford
home page I've put a link at the bottom
and it's the one almost the last one at
Stanford because they're alphabetical
Stanford engineering hero talk and then
that'll take you to a PDF with a number
links for downloading things but I found
it interesting that two of the seven
heroes have made this their issue and
bothered bill Perry's got in grief for
being a fool John Deutsch the former
director of the CIA and Harold Brown a
former Secretary of Defense both in
democratic administrations had a an
op-ed criticizing an earlier op-ed by
Shultz Perry Kissinger none and they
calling for a return to the vision of
Reykjavik a return to the vision of a
world free of nuclear weapons they don't
know how we're going to get there they
don't even know if we can get there but
they think we need to have that vision
and deutschen Brown titled their op-ed
the nuclear disarmament fantasy that's
not the same as saying the fool's errand
but it's basically the same now the
basic argument that people make as to
why it's foolish not everybody but a lot
of people make this argument is nuclear
weapons have kept the peace for 68 years
we haven't had a world war in 68 years
don't mess with success that ain't broke
don't fix it in fact one professor
Mearsheimer at Chicago I think has
called them weapons of peace that was in
his defense his paper and foreign
affairs printed the most prestigious
Foreign Affairs journal why Iran should
get the bomb arguing that it'll make the
Mideast safer
rather than more dangerous he actually
makes some good arguments I don't agree
with the conclusion though with that
Iran should get the bomb now when I was
working with beyond war in the 80s I had
one of the things I contributed was the
what I call the inevitability argument
sure it's been 68 years without a world
war but how many how long do we think we
can go and what I argued was actually
helps to go back to the Cuban Missile
Crisis first in 1962 after the Cuban
crisis was over President Kennedy said
that the odds of war and his opinion had
been and this is a quote somewhere
between one out of three and even now if
he was right the Cuban Missile Crisis
was quite
like playing Russian roulette with a two
or three chambered revolver with the
whole world pointed at the world's head
I call it nuclear roulette
now other Wars other crises have a
smaller risk for example the Georgian
war in 2008 might have had a hundred
chambers in the gun maybe even a
thousand but it doesn't matter whether
the gun has two chambers three chambers
six chambers a hundred or a thousand if
you keep pulling the trigger in the
inevitability argument what's going to
happen you're gonna kill yourself it's
not a question of if it's a question of
when now over the last 10 years I came
back to that argument and I tried to
shoot holes in it a good way to come up
with new results the only argument I
found that held water was that same
inevitability argument could be applied
to an extinction-level asteroid hitting
the earth the dinosaurs were probably
killed in such an event 65 million years
ago but there hasn't been one since and
we know there's a lot of data that
indicates and we could be quite
confident that these extinction level
asteroids hit the earth they don't kill
everything but they kill off the vast
majority of species potentially
including human beings they happen about
every hundred million years which says
that over the next year there's one
chance in 100 million of it happening
now if the risk of nuclear deterrence
failing and are destroying ourselves is
one in a hundred million per year then
the risk is it probably acceptable it's
comparable to the asteroids but if the
risk is one in a hundred per year so we
expect nuclear deterrence to work for a
hundred years so the sixty-eight years
we've seen is only very minimal evidence
a child born today has an 80 year life
expectancy what would be the risk to
that child if it's 1% a year
worse than 50% it's not quite 80% it
grows linearly first and then tail saw
but it's worse than 50% odds that's not
good and so what I saw was we we had to
try to estimate the quantitatively the
risk of nuclear deterrence failing and I
had no idea how to do this but I went
around then this is one of the great
things about being at Stanford
we have professor n curmudgeon in civil
and environmental engineering when I met
with her a lot of people gave me other
advice there was nowhere near as helpful
and said you need to look at
quantitative risk analysis the same
thing happened when I talked with
Professor Elizabeth pate Cornell who's
kind of MS risk analysis she's one of
the world's leading experts in the area
and also I need to acknowledge Dwane
Steffi dr. Dwayne Steffi at exponent
incorporated formally failure analysis
who also put me on to this was all kind
of happening about the same time I'd
never heard of quantitative risk
analysis before but I learned I decided
I need to learn what this was
quantitative risk analysis allows you to
assess the risk of catastrophic events
that have not yet occurred not perfectly
but much more accurately much more
objectively much less subjectively than
just arguing it's too risky no it isn't
and I realized that this was the
fundamental question that had to be
answered because those people saying
don't mess with success it couldn't say
that if the risk is 1% a year they could
say it if it's one in a hundred million
per year and this seemed like the magic
bullet and this was reinforced by early
success I went to Don Kennedy the former
president of Stanford University with a
wrote a statement of support for
applying this approach he signed it
within 24 hours
Bill caves former dean of engineering
same thing two Nobel laureates martin
pearl in physics can arrow and economics
signed on again almost immediately
hearing about it and admiral inman my
former adversary turned friend at NSA
looked at it and he agreed that it made
sense he signed it by the way in
addition to being former director of NSA
and deputy director of the CIA admiral
inman was nominated to be Secretary of
Defense in the 90s by President Clinton
but withdrew his name for various
reasons so this is a man who really
understands national security dick
Garwin whose name probably doesn't mean
as much to you but this man he's Enrico
Fermi was his advisor
he says dick Garland's the one true
genius I ever met and he was one of the
key people in making the first h-bomb
and he's highly respected within the
defense community and he signed on so I
thought this was it's working this is
good this is going to solve the problem
unfortunately in the five years since
not much has happened I was back in
Washington in October trying to get
Congress which I've been trying to do
for five years to authorize the National
Research Council National Academy study
and it's not going to happen with this
Congress no way so but I'm still trying
I've swung and a lot of wild pitches on
this one too but I'm still you can I
think you can tell I'm still excited and
we're still gonna find a way to make it
work if any of you have ideas you got
some connections could be in other
countries we could get the National
Academy of Sciences and some other
country if it's up to it doing something
like this so how does quantitative risk
analysis work it breaks down a
catastrophic failure so here's normal
behavior here's catastrophe it doesn't
just look at the jump it recognizes that
there's a chain an accident chain that
takes you there good example is the
Concorde the supersonic transport fatal
crash in 2000 after almost 25 years of
crash free experience prior to the fatal
crash it was the safest airliner to fly
and we spaced on the empirical
statistics no fatalities per billion met
passenger miles flown after the crash it
was the most dangerous airliner to fly
by more than a factor of 10 possibly a
factor of 100 there's some numbers I
haven't been able to get ahold of that's
because there were so few Conchords and
the accident occurred because a piece of
debris on the runway hit a tire the tire
blew out that blow out hit a fuel tank
causing it to rupture causing a fuel
leak leading to a fire leading to the
crash accident sequence now we've never
seen a fatal crash of the concorde but
we've seen a lot of tire failures and a
lot of fuel leaks it was known prior to
the crash that the concorde had a
problem with tire failures not double
that of the normal jetliner fleet not
five times not 10 times but 60 times
higher than that of the normal jetliner
fleet six thousand percent above normal
and in more than 10% of those tire
failures fuel leaks occurred as a result
it was a disaster waiting to happen but
nobody had the guts no one was foolish
enough to say we should ground the
Concord he would have been called or she
would have been called Chicken Little
Cassandra so there's an example where if
Q are a quantitative risk analysis had
been applied to the conquered I suspect
it would have been grounded long before
the fatal crash what are some of the
partial failures of so it looks at is
these partial failures the excursions
from normalcy prior to catastrophe have
we seen any of those with nuclear
deterrence Cuban Missile Crisis 1962 is
the one most people know about there are
a whole bunch of others unfortunately
that most people don't know about there
was almost a repeat of the Cuban crisis
of 62 in July 2008 almost no one knows
about it including most of my well now
they do because I've told them but most
of my colleagues over in SESAC which
studies these things it just didn't make
the news but in analyzing the Cuban
Missile Crisis I've identified six key
mistakes that took us there and in my
opinion five-and-a-half of those
mistakes had been repeated in July 2008
and we were half a step short of being
there because the last half step did not
occur almost no one knows about it but
the same thing could happen again it has
to do with our missile defense system
and the Russian objections to it
basically they threatened to put bombers
in Cuba to hopscotch over it the Georgia
War of August 2008 was not as big an
excursion but still an excursion and if
the July 2008 Cuban bomber mini-crisis
had Cowen's been a month later during
the August 2008 Georgian war it would
have made things much more dangerous
these overlaps are really something have
to watch out for Mideast wars in 67 and
73 both produced nuclear near misses
another me nice mid east working out the
same effect India and Pakistan have
nuclear weapons and have fought several
wars including one admittedly smaller
than the others when they both were
nuclear armed and there are other
examples involving terrorism that I'm
going to skip over
the solution to the problem is to go
first was to take an engineering
approach it's to look at it not just in
isolation not just as nuclear war not
just as war but what are the precursors
to war it turns out you can even go
further back a lot of it has to do with
the assumptions that we make then we
don't even know our assumptions we take
them as self-evident truths and they if
you have wrong assumptions in your logic
no matter how logical you are from there
on out it's a house of cards and in the
notes for this talk which you'll be able
to get online in fact they're gonna said
I think Jamie said they're gonna send it
to everyone who's registered as well I
have a link to my class notes on this
it's it's the section on critical
thinking and one of them for example is
the fact the first assumption that I
list there is the u.s. is the world's
sole remaining superpower you read that
so often you can't help but almost
believe it's true or believe it's true
but it's more complicated than that the
United States is the world's sole
conventional superpower we spend almost
as much money on our military as the
rest of the world combined
so we if nuclear weapons don't get mixed
into it we can we're king of the
mountain but nuclear weapons are the
great equalizer it's why Iran is
probably seeking a nuclear weapons
capability it's why North Korea won't
give them theirs up and in the case of
Russia and China they can destroy our
homeland in under an hour we are not the
world sole remaining superpower without
qualification and if we act as if we are
we may threaten and we actually have
been threatening what at least Russia
and I think China to perceive as their
vital national interest we may not see
it that way but that's not what matters
so we need to really think things
through more carefully the nice thing
about critical thinking is unlike
nuclear disarmament which I'm not
proposing in this talk people could say
that's risky and I would tend to agree
instantaneous unilateral nuclear
disarmament my
be very risky it might not do we ought
to examine that but that's not I'm
proposing what's the risk in
re-examining the assumptions that
underlie our worldview like the u.s.
being the world's sole remaining
superpower and I've got 19 others in
those notes and you form your own
opinion what's the risk in re-examining
them and rooting out those that are
false no risk in fact it has the
opposite effect it will increase our
national security so I'm skipping over a
couple of things because it always takes
longer than I think I think I'll end
here with just a few concluding remarks
there will be links to a number of these
further it's suggested reading and also
have the quotes from the four other
fools Vint Cerf Brad Park and soon and
so on but what I hope I've done is I
hope I've encouraged you to not be
afraid of appearing foolish it sometimes
is very very wise and I want to thank
Stanford for giving me the freedom to do
that here thank you
I just before I have to thank my wife
for not only giving me the freedom to do
foolish things but actually leading me
through some of these questions we have
a few minutes for questions comments in
doing foolish things as a PhD student
versus a tenured professor I actually
think you have more freedom as a PhD
student when you're a tenured professor
you have to keep your contracts flowing
so that we can pay your research
assistantships and you're kind of cut
caught in a groove or rut which it's all
fit it's all a matter of perspective
when I was a graduate student I looked
at some really crazy things
I mean you shouldn't spend too much of
your time on on the moon you have to but
because you do want to get through at
some point but I think graduate students
actually have more freedom than
professors to to look at these things
let's see that it has the work of
Chauncy star figured in any of it say
say a little more okay remind me the
names familiar but it's not ringing
about sociological relationships
removing the risk yes the director of
red cream oh right no I haven't looked
at that and I will need to do it there
are other people working on this there's
a group on catastrophic risk at I think
Cambridge and so there are some people
looking at these things but they in my
opinion they don't give enough attention
to the nuclear risk which is the one
that it could just happen like this and
be all over I pay attention to global
warming as you can see from my work with
the EPA
but that's one that is a more gradual
although there are some potential and
this is another example where
engineering comes into it you may get
yourself into a situation where you -
you don't see the immediate impact of it
but you've set things in motion that you
can't stop what am i proposing the
Congress authorized it is to authorize
and fun because the National Academies
does not have a big budget it's not a
lot of money by DRD standards and I'd
get none of it by the way it means more
unpaid work for me it would be a taking
a look at quantitative applying
quantitative risk analysis to a
potential failure of nuclear deterrence
they would not necessarily do the
analysis themselves because that I think
that's going to require full-time 20 or
30 people working for a long period of
time but this would really be does qra
make sense here some people would think
it doesn't but I think the risk
framework just by itself helps you see a
lot of things like as soon as I point
out that even if nuclear deterrence
would work for a hundred years
that is 1% a year a child born today has
worse than even odds of surviving the 68
years that we've survived with a number
of near misses doesn't look so good
dangerous human behavior that's going to
lead to a nuclear assault of some sort
how do you quantify dangerous human
dangerous human human behavior that
might lead to a nuclear catastrophe
that's part of what they'd have to look
at my current view is how it might
happen is we look at these excursions
and so Cuban Missile Crisis we'd regard
on a scale of 10 where 10 is nuclear war
is highly probable you know close to 50
50 it was a 10 abel archer which you
probably haven't heard of except you
probably have because we talk in
november 83 i think was about an 8 but
i've been talking to somebody who thinks
it was it he thinks it was a 10.5 he
thinks it was worse than this is a
former CIA analyst he also he thinks
there was another one the nineteen
ninety-five Norwegian meteorological
rocket
false alarm basically the nuclear
football the Russian nuclear footballs
opened in front of Yeltsin for the first
time and he was either drunk enough or
sober enough to make the right decision
he didn't push the button most of us who
look at it see it at least most of the
people here at Stanford I talked to see
it as an 8 or something like that on the
scale
but some people see it as more dangerous
than the Cuban Missile Crisis because
they maintain if he pushed the button it
would have all been over then it only
occupied a short period of time and it
doesn't occupy a big mindshare in our in
our minds because we didn't live through
it we didn't even know what's happening
at the time so we look at how often
these excursions occur and how far and
then we'd only have to estimate the
subjective estimates would be what's the
probability of an event of that
magnitude leading to a first use of
nuclear weapons it's like in the case of
the Cuban Missile Crisis there were two
things that nearly went to the use of
nuclear weapons and would likely happen
in a repeat of something like that
there was a lot of pressure on President
Kennedy to invade Cuba in fact even
before the missiles were discovered Time
magazine had an article in September
1962 which I have a copy of in which
they said the only basically invade Cuba
now and what we didn't know is that the
Soviets had placed battlefield nuclear
weapons on Cuba to repel just such an
invasion and so if our troops had come
ashore they would have been vaporized
and several Soviet submarines were
forced to surface near the quarantine
line we didn't know they had nuclear
torpedoes on board and according to the
crew of one of them be 59 the captain
came close to using it we don't know how
true that is but their indication so
you'd look at you look just like with
the Concorde you'd look at how often
tires are failing you look at how often
you get fuel leaks and then you try to
estimate from there but there are other
ways one might do it Jim go ahead
question is he's read that some people
say that terrorists getting their hands
on a nuclear weapon by stealing it or or
at least a dirty bomb
is fairly simple why hasn't it happened
I don't think it's as simple as they
make it out to be that's not my and my
expertise is broader than that but we do
have to watch it the Air Force the
United States Air Force lost six nuclear
weapons for 36 hours in 2007 when you
have 8,000 weapons which is roughly what
the United States has today it's hard to
keep track of all of them and these were
improperly guarded during the time that
they were lost so we I don't know
exactly what the risk is but I see some
ways we could make the risk lower in
fact in a statement that Don Kennedy
bill Kay's admiral inman and the other
signed its main thrust is toward getting
the study done of applying qra to
nuclear deterrence but it has a
statement toward the end it says
something it says almost exactly this as
an example of an early step that might
be taken to reduce the risk a few
hundred nuclear weapons would deter an
irrational adversary and no number would
deter an irrational adversary meaning
terrorists either side in the United
States or Russia or China for that
matter could therefore make reductions
in their Arsenal's with little to no
loss in national security and it then
goes on to say it could even be argued
that it would enhance national security
by reducing the risk that terrorists get
their hands on one so we should be
taking and by the way Shultz Perry
Kissinger not our focus primarily on
nuclear terrorism and trying to minimize
that threat
percent chance of having gone next from
here
DC problem is getting bigger
change and actually get people to do
whatever that you worked on that easy
problem how do you get people to do
what's in their cell matrix no question
it's very hard the fundamental problem
is not nuclear weapons the fundamental
problem is that technology engineering
has given us godlike power power that
traditionally only God was supposed to
have the ability to create new AI forms
have that power we can do it today with
genetic engineering destroy civilization
nuclear weapons we have that power
through engineering great floods and so
we have this our physical power is
godlike is our maturity level as a
species godlike no where is it I'd say
at best it's irresponsible adolescent
there's some very responsible
adolescence but irresponsible 16-year
old so I the Annette and so as I look at
it there's an underlying problem to all
of these problems and that it you don't
have to work on am individual we really
have to work on growing up as a species
and I focus on nuclear weapons because
it's the one where it's hardest for
people to say let's wait and see I'm
hoping though if we see the horrendous
risk that we've taken here the
horrendous mess we've gotten ourselves
into and the tremendous luck or grace of
God or whatever you want to call it why
we've survived in spite of that that
will then wake up and apply it in other
areas as well and solve these other
problems instead of saying let's wait
and see but it's a tricky one I actually
have talked with Carol Dweck in our
psychology department she her research
is on why some people when confronted by
a she works at the individual level
although I think she has a recent paper
that's gone in this direction and I'm I
would maybe our conversation that's
something to do with it highly respected
bestseller books her research is why
some people when confronted by a task
that's above their current ability level
a lot of people run away
but some people are actually attracted
by it they kind of go oh goody here's a
chance for me to learn something new and
what she found is people have one of two
mindsets typically one she calls the
fixed mindset where ability is fixed and
immutable you're born with a certain
amount of it you can't change it so what
do you think those people do when
confronted by a task they don't know how
to solve they run away they don't want
to appear stupid foolish other people
have a mindset where ability is like a
muscle if you do exercise you can
enhance your ability and those are the
people who run toward the mindset having
toward the these these problems and she
found that it was possible to pull
people depending on how you phrased the
problem people with the fixed mindset
could actually be pulled somewhat in the
other direction if you first told them
about people who would overcome
adversity for example Einstein having
learning disabilities as a child having
difficulty in school and only later
doing his great work and in fact bill
Spicer are caught now deceased colleague
who was great man in solid-state theory
I had a wonderful conversation with him
in which he said yeah when I was a kid
they diagnosed me as I mean at
the top of his field later he was
dyslexic highly dyslexic and so if you
emphasize the ability of people to
overcome and to to to learn from it from
problems that are above them then they
tend to move toward it in the same way
when I read about her work I said this
is what I've been confronting at a
societal level I can't count the number
of times people have told me you can't
change human nature even if survival is
at stake and so when we worked in beyond
war we kind of understood this at an
intuitive level because we always talked
about the seemingly impossible changes
the fools errands like the suffragettes
working on women voting I mean it's
going to destroy the family women
obviously couldn't vote for the you know
for the right person they're too
emotional and getting rid of slavery we
did that at an intuitive level but I
tried to make a case and my wisdom of
foolishness
helps I'm hoping is helping to do that
but we need to know more about how to do
that one or two more yes yeah I actually
recommend the Doomsday Clock is the
bullet near the atomic scientists have
this Doomsday Clock I think it's five
minutes to midnight right now and it was
back in the 90s when times were better
between the US and Russia back at 17
minutes to midnight if I remember I've
argued that the Doomsday Clock is not
the right thing that it really should be
a risk per unit time see that's the
fundamental mistake that people make
they say what's the risk of a nuclear
war it's the wrong units it's what's the
risk per year I mean the risk over time
is a hundred percent if we don't drive
it rapidly to zero and so that's
actually the the solution and so I argue
that they should have a risk meter
rather than a minute to midnight meter
but they didn't go for it and I can it's
too too much invested in that what would
I do to diminish the risk well first of
all even if I wanted to get rid of
nuclear weapons immediately
it can't happen it's going to take years
to dismantle all these bill Perry in the
talks was talking about how long it's
going to take to get rid of 20,000
nuclear weapons what I'm arguing we need
to do and actually we know this from
mathematics we need to drive the risk to
zero rapidly enough we need to keep
reducing the risk and not stop when
we've reduced it by an order of
magnitude okay that's good but we still
have to reduce it further we can't give
up if we were to have as a goal having
the risk every decade which I believe is
quite doable especially since the
initial steps involve things like
treating Russia with some respect I mean
we may not like their political system
but I don't like the Saudi Arabian
printed Palazzo stem and we do just fine
with them why have we de modified
Russia and so if we can start reducing
the risk by a factor of two over the
next decade and reduce it again by a
factor of two over the next decade and
keep doing that and not give up even
when we're reduced it by a factor of a
hundred compared to now we have to keep
working at it that child if it's 1% a
year right now that child with an 80
year life expectancy would have roughly
a 10% risk over the first decade of his
or her life 5% over the next decade two
and a half percent over the next decade
it would add up to 20% which is still
horrible assuming assuming it's 1% but
it's a lot better than the rough I think
60% risk that the child bears now if we
can reduce it by a factor of two every
five years instead we would roughly have
it again down to 10% and maybe the
annual risk right now is below 1% maybe
it's more like 1/2 of 1% but that's what
yep
they hand out the suggested reading
we'll have examples I have a seminar
called nuclear weapons risk and hope and
all the handouts are online and there
will be a link to the handout list one
final question yes was money one of
their reasons for President Obama to get
the New START treaty ratified which cut
the number of nuclear weapon deployed
nuclear weapons that the US and Russia
have to 1554 a little over 2000 he was
he agreed to fund I think 85 billion
dollars additional over and above the
weapons grabs national lapses they're
now called
budgets over the next 10 years and
what's happened to that I believe from
what I've been reading because I haven't
been following it totally closely that
agreement is now in question both
because there's the sequesteration issue
and also Jon Kyl who required that
before he would consider voting for
didn't vote
a lot of people that require that other
Republican senators notably Johnny
Isakson from Georgia and corker from
Tennessee are getting upset with Obama
that he's now questioning whether he'll
he'll fund that so there is food and
drink out in the lobby we'd walk him in
and say we're you think Marnie will
he'll be around be able to stay for a
little bit and obviously they're lost
you